[Applaus]
[Musik]
merkt euch die folgende schlagzeile denn
sie hat sehr viel mit den heutigen video
zu tun
sanktionen drohen großbritanniens
position als spielwiese russische
oligarchen ersten sanktionen gegen
großen könnten dass moskau an der themse
hart treffen aber bevor wir uns in
diesem thema beschäftigen möchte ich
euch eine frage stellen was meint ihr
wie viele dollar-millionäre es auf der
welt gibt hunderttausend eine million 5
millionen nein wir sprechen heute von
mehr als 50 millionen millionären auf
der ganzen welt aber die vielleicht
beeindruckendste tatsache dabei ist dass
es sich bei den allermeisten dieser
fälle nicht unbemerkt ist vermögen
handelt 354 millionärin sind heute ist
es mit millionär das heißt sie haben
ihren reichtum aus eigener kraft
geschaffen und habt ihr euch jemals
gefragt wo diese menschen am liebsten
leben wollen was sind die lieblingsziel
der reichsten menschen der welt ich bin
sicher er wird und worauf diese frage
hinaus läuft wenn ja die stadt mit den
meisten millionären auf der welt ist
nicht nichts singapur nicht dubai und so
gar nicht das kleine juwel miami nein es
ist die 9 millionen metropole an der
themse landet
[Musik]
in der britischen hauptstadt gibt es
etwa 900.000 menschen denen
nettovermögen eine million dollar
übersteigt mit anderen worten wenn du
nach london ist erst besitzt ungefähr
jeder zehnte den du auf der straße
trifft mehr als eine million dollar und
das ist noch nicht alles sondern steht
auch auf der liste der städte mit den
meisten mega reichen also milliardären
und zwar immerhin an siebter stelle mehr
als 60 von ihnen leben an der themse
[Musik]
und die frage ist warum haben sie sich
gerade london ausgesucht ich meine
london ist nicht gerade eine stadt die
für sonne strand und mojitos bei
sonnenuntergang bekannt ist würdest du
wenn du aus gesorgt hätte es an einem
ort leben wollen der vor allem für sein
deprimierendes regenwetter und 24
stunden dauerstaus bekannte ist es
stellt sich also die frage was london
hat dass so viele millionäre und
milliardäre ansieht okay die kurze
antwort wäre so etwas wie aber markt das
ganze ist doch sonnenklar diese dort wo
eben das große geld verdient wird und in
gewisser weise ist das auch so london
ist eines der beiden großen
finanzzentren der welt das andere ist
übrigens new york wir sprechen hier von
einem ort an dem investoren aus allen
ecken der welt zusammenkommen
wenn du eine regierung oder ein großes
unternehmen west und pro system aus den
landesmitteln aufbringen willst wirst du
in der britischen hauptstadt
wahrscheinlich die richtigen leuten
umgeht dabei weiterhelfen können fast 20
prozent aller internationalen bank liter
über zwölf prozent aller börsennotierten
internationalen anleihen haben ihren
ursprung in großbritannien außerdem dass
london die derivate hauptstadt der welt
in das zentrum von mehr als 40 prozent
des weltweiten devisenhandels wir
sprechen von einer riesigen drehscheibe
für finanzdienstleistungen aller art
einer stadt in der auch die
europazentralen hunderter multinationale
unternehmen angesiedelt sind auch nach
dem wechsel die so genannte soft power
niedrige steuern sowie flexibel und
aufdringliche vorschriften haben london
zu einem weltweiten epizentrum für
finanzaktivitäten gemacht
[Musik]
in london werden sogar mehr dollars
gehandelt als in den usa selbst und wenn
euch das ist irgendwie komisch klingen
dürft ihr gespannt sein gedreht über
dieses kuriosum bald ein eigenes video
also abo und glöckchen nicht vergessen
london ist also an die globale
moneymaker rakete und menschen mit geld
mögen orte an denen sie noch mehr geld
verdienen und gleichzeitig die vermögen
in sicherheit bringen können wir reden
hier über den heiligen gral der
prosperität rechtssicherheit
[Musik]
diese ist nun mal die grundvoraussetzung
für den wohlstand eines jeden landes und
neben all diesen faktoren die der
schlüssel zum erfolg londons und
großbritanniens im allgemeinen sind gibt
es noch einen weiteren grund den
hervorheben können und den viele von
euch vielleicht nicht kennen das
sogenannte tier wollen visum allgemein
bekannt als goldenes wieso nun ja auf
den ersten blick handelt es sich um eine
brilliante idee aber wie alles hat sie
ihre vor und nachteile und wie so oft
ist es ein vorteil ob das anderen
nachteil weswegen die britische
regierung das tier wollen visum als
eines der mittel zur bestrafung
russlands für den einmarsch in die
ukraine identifiziert hat oder besser
gesagt als eines der mittel zur
bestrafung der oligarch wladimir putin
unterstützen
eu-parlamentarier drängen auf ein verbot
neuer goldener pässe und visa für russen
regierung johnson beendet goldne visa
für russische oligarchen
das britische vorgehen gegen russische
oligarchen könnte das ende für london
grad bedeuten die wohlhabenden elite
werben gezwungen sich zwischen ihren
reichtum ihren luxus ihrer zukunft und
der unterstützung von wladimir putin zu
entscheiden und deshalb legen wir so
politik zuschauer erzählen durch in
diesem video wie das war eigentlich die
königreich versucht hat multi millionäre
und milliardäre aus allen ecken der welt
anzuziehen und wie dieses konzept gerade
implodiert wegen der vielen express visa
es die hunderten von russischen
oligarchen gewährt worden also lasst uns
sofort loslegen
[Musik]
das wiederum für reiche
zunächst einmal ein wichtiger hinweis
goldene visa es gibt ist nicht nur im
vereinigten königreich tatsächlich gibt
es 23 länder auf der welt die ein
solches visum haben jedes mit seinen
eigenen besonderheiten
selbst in ländern wie griechenland und
spanien welche ja nicht gerade als die
unternehmerfreundlich sind orte der welt
bekannt selbst in solche visa an
investitionen vermögenswerte wie
immobilien aktien und der staatsschulden
geburt in spanien zum beispiel wurde ein
solches modell im jahr 2013 eingeführt
um einen absatzmarkt für viele der leer
stehenden immobilien zu schaffen die
unverkauft blieben als die
immobilienblase 2008 zu klassen begann
auf diese weise kannst du in spanien
eine aufenthaltserlaubnis kaufen wenn du
eine immobilie im wert von mindestens
500.000 euro erwirkt
tatsächlich ist dies gerade nach dem
wechsel ein gutes geschäft für spanien
und mittelmeerländer im allgemeinen
geworden denn viele briten haben den
kauf von dortigen immobilien in der
region gezogen um eine eu
aufenthaltserlaubnis zu erhalten mit der
sie geschäfte machen arbeiten und ohne
weitere einschränkungen in der eu ein
und ausgehen können ried nutzen jetzt
die goldenen visa regeln der eu länder
um ihre reise rechte zurück zu gewinnen
und das ist genau dasselbe was auch
viele russen getan haben schau dir
einfach mal die mittelmeerküste in
südspanien an trotzdem im vergleich zu
london ist das nichts und viele von euch
fragen sich vielleicht warum sie sich
vor allem auf das goldene visum des
vereinigten königreichs konzentrieren
[Musik]
die wahl ist nämlich dass nur wenige
länder mit dieser art von programm ist
so viel erfolg hatte wie großbritannien
und auch so viele kontroversen ausgelöst
haben seit seiner einführung im jahr
2008 haben mehr als 12.000 millionäre
und ihre familien dank des tirol visums
eine neue heimat im inselkönigreich
gefunden
nach mehreren verschärfungen runden was
die anforderungen an geht müssen derzeit
mindestens zwei millionen pfund in
unternehmen oder in anleihen investiert
werden die im land registriert außerdem
kann man mit dieser art von visum später
auch eine unbegrenzte
aufenthaltsgenehmigung beantragen und
diese frist verkürzt sich noch je mehr
man investiert ja ein gewisser weise ist
das ja auch so eine pay to win
geschäftsmodell sowie diese dopamin
fallen games die bei uns immer wieder
als sponsor anfragen die wir aber auch
immer wieder abblitzen lassen der
endlich will hier keine werbung für
glücksspiele die uns gamern auf
unlautere weise nur das geld aus der
tasche ziehen wollen egal wie viel sie
uns bieten und leute ich komme ich
verraten dass sie meist fast doppelt so
viel bieten als andere sponsoren und
zwar aus gutem grund aber wie auch immer
zurück nach großbritannien auch da geld
wenn du geld gut investitionen ins
königreich springst werden die die türen
weit geöffnet
aber dann bist du auch erst mal lockt
mit alten investitionen und wenn es dann
geopolitisch drunter und drüber geht
kann das schon mal unangenehm werden so
wie er es der auch dann stellt sich
allerdings auch die frage welche
auswirkungen diese regelungen auf das
allgemeinen wirtschaftsleben haben ist
dieses tirol visum für das land von
vorteil oder eher nicht
[Musik]
nun laut der britischen regierung selbst
ist der zweck dieser visa die
investition und die kapitalisierung
heimischer unternehmen zu erhöhen auf
diese weise würde die wirtschaftswege
und es würden mehr arbeitsplätze
geschaffen und davon profitiere dann
auch den mittel und arbeiterklasse denn
je mehr unternehmen ist gibt und die
robuster sind desto besser so alle daher
kann das britische goldene visum grunde
genommen als ein dynamisches element für
die wirtschaft angesehen werden wir
sprechen von einem instrument das es
geschafft hat zig milliarden pfund an
produktiven investitionen ins königreich
zu bringen
klingt gut nicht wahr natürlich haben
diese arten von systemen auch ihre
schwächen viele kritiker waren davor
dass es sich um eine art sicheren hafen
für vermögende handelt die ihren
reichtum gelinde gesagt auch nicht sehr
saubere art in ländern erworben haben in
den rechtsstaatlichkeit und kontrollen
fehlen aber ironischerweise dienen sie
auch als zufluchtsort für viele menschen
die dann dieser visa von tyrannen aller
arten können
[Musik]
täter und opfer treffen exil so oft
wieder aufeinander was zusätzlichen
spannungen und kriminalität im gastland
füllen kann aber dieses problem kennt
man ja auch aus dem asylrecht und hatte
ein eigenes video verdient denn die
frage mit der wir uns heute beschäftigen
wollen ist ein anderer ratet mal welche
investoren am meisten von den britischen
tiere und visa profitiert haben nach
321 genau wie die chinesen und die
russen ganz besonders die außen und
letztere breiten downing street nicht
erst seit dem krieg in der ukraine
riesige kopfschmerzen habt ihr schon mal
was von london gerade gehört aufgepasst
willkommene landen grad
[Musik]
eben jahr 2015 liegt auf dem russischen
fernsehsender sts die serie london grad
an eine tv sitcom über eine agentur die
sich darauf spezialisiert hat probleme
von russische millionäre in london zu
lösen und der platz dieser serie so gaga
und ränder - auch erscheinen mag ist in
wirklichkeit ganz und gar nicht gaga und
rändern die handlungsstränge sind gar
nicht so weit hergeholt
von den rund 12.000 inhabern eines
britischen goldene visums sind etwa 20
prozent russen dafür gibt es natürlich
eine erklärung und für diese müssen wir
in die jahre 2008 bis 2015 zurückreisen
dies war eine zeit die in großbritannien
als blindes vertrauen bekannt ist sagen
wir mal so damals hatte das visa
programm nur wenige anforderungen und
vor allem gab es kaum kontrollen niemand
scherte sich darum wer die empfänger der
golden visa wirklich waren und woher ihr
vermögen stammte
und wer konnte sich diese gelegenheit
nicht entgehen lassen natürlich die
oligarchen sie stürmten die insel wie
einst die normannen
[Musik]
in den jahren 2008 bis 2014 wurden 85
prozent aller goldenen visa an russische
investoren vergeben aber als die
anforderungen verschärft wurden hat sich
der zustrom von einreisenden aus den
russischen mutterland natürlich stark
verlangsamt sagt 2015 machen russen nur
noch 15 prozent aus das ist immer noch
ein hoher prozentsatz aber nicht mehr so
krass nun ja es scheint so als ob viele
der russischen millionäre die in
großbritannien investieren und leben
wollen nicht sehr glücklich darüber sind
dass die britischen behörden in ihren
vermögensverhältnissen herumschnüffeln
wollen aber ich denke das sollte
niemanden wirklich überrascht wurden
fakt ist dass die britische regierung
eines tages plötzlich merkte dass die
ganze geschichte ziemlich aus dem ruder
läuft verdammt stark aus dem ruder vor
allem weil sich das land mit putin
freundlichen oligarchen und ihrer ganzen
entourage füllte und mit ihnen wuchs
auch der einfluss des kreml auf die
britische wirtschaft laut transparency
international haben hochrangige
russische beamte und politischen wie mit
dem kreml verbunden sind seit 2000 16
immobilien im wert von mehr als 1,5
milliarden pfund erworben und ganz
sicher ist die tatsächliche zahl
angesichts der intransparenz mit der
diese leute operieren viel viel höher
immobilien sind allerdings nur die
spitze des eisbergs und mittlerweile
wird immer klarer dass dieser ganze
leicht sind aus geostrategischer sicht
nicht die beste idee war
ganz zu schweigen davon dass viele
dieser menschen es gewohnt sind alles zu
tun oder zu lassen was ihnen gerade ein
stellt nicht nur in bezug auf ihre
eigenen angelegenheiten sondern auch in
bezug auf die anderer menschen für viele
von ihnen stellen dinge wie
rechtsstaatlichkeit wettbewerb oder
dreist unternehmertum schwächen da die
auf der westlichen weichheit und
dekadenz büro klar sie nehmen all diese
dinge wäre das für sich selbst in
anspruch wenn sie ihnen vorteile bringen
aber identifizieren werden sie sich mit
ihnen nie und nimmer sie sind schlicht
und ergreifend nicht wirklich
integrationsfähig auch wenn sie immer
das gegenteil vorgeben und wir wissen ja
welch schreckliche konsequenzen die
mangelnde integrationsfähigkeit oder
fehlender integrationswille von
einwanderern für die aufnehmende
gesellschaft haben kann in diesem fall
sind die folgen vielleicht noch
schlimmer als wenn es sich um armut
giganten handelt denn die oligarchen
migrieren ja nicht ins sozialsystem ein
in die unterste schicht der
volkswirtschaft sondern in die oberste
in die führungsetagen der wirtschaft und
mit ihnen sieht dort eine kultur ein die
dem allgemeinen geschäftsklima nicht
gerade zuträglich ist ihre methoden
weiten sich dann von oben nach unten im
gesamten wirtschaftsgefüge aus und
machen dort noch lange nicht halt viele
dieser oligarchen haben direkt oder
indirekt versucht die britische politik
zu beeinflussen denn putins anweisung an
seine kaposvar glasklar auch auf der
insel sollte ein korruptes netzwerk mit
vom kreml abhängigen polit marionetten
installiert werden wie dies in ländern
wie deutschland ungarn oder tschechien
gelungen war doch die briten zogen die
reißleine
2015 bereits bedacht die britischen
behörden mit der verschärfung der
zugangsbedingungen und kontrollen es
wurde sogar eine rückwirkende
untersuchung von mehr als 6000 goldenen
dieser eingeleitet das ergebnis etwa die
hälfte aller ausgestellten visa wurde
oder wird überprüft oder gegen ihre
inhaber wird ermittelt und der wohl
prominenteste dieser 3000 fälle ist der
von roman abramowitsch
[Applaus]
abramowitsch ist ein bekannter russische
oligarch und besitzer des fußballclubs
chelsea der 2018 seinen antrag auf
verlängerung des visums zurückzog weil
gegen ihn zunehmend wegen seiner
geschäfte ermittelt wurde er ist einer
jener typen die bis in die letzte pore
gewaschen werden wollen ohne dabei nass
zu werden auf der einen seite gibt er
sich als westlich und integriert nun
sogar solidarisch mit der ukraine auch
weil sein motor ukrainischer abstammung
ist präsident selensky sprach sich dafür
aus ihn erstmal nicht zu sanktionieren
da als wanderer zwischen den welten von
gut und böse zwischen ihm und putin
vermitteln können im rahmen dieser
verhandlungen wurde abramowitsch dann
auch prompt opfer eines mutmaßlichen
anschlags durch kreml hardliner den er
jedoch überlebt hat auf der anderen
seite ist er jedoch auch einer der
hauptnutznießer des kleptokraten systems
das vom kreml und putin entwickelt und
aufrechterhalten wird abramowitsch war
bereits einer der hauptprofiteure der
ersten oligarchischen generation die
ihre reichtümer während der
manipulierten privatisierung von
staatsbetrieben unter präsident jelzin
zusammenklauben konnte und er schafft er
es als einer der wenigen auch in der ära
putin weiterhin zu den hobbys der kreml
kleptokratie zu gehören mehr noch er war
wohl einer der drahtzieher bei putins
machtergreifung im jahr 1999 es war
nämlich abramowitsch der je ziel als
erster putin als nachfolger im amt des
russischen präsidenten empfahl und
seitdem scheint abramowitsch einer der
ganz großen handlanger putin zu sein vor
allem ein finanzieller mittels markt
dies wird von us geheimdienstkreisen
immer wieder bestätigt ja wir wissen
blut putins ein handlanger fürstlich wie
jeder kluge mafia pate zeigt er sich
nach jedem großen haupt zug besonders
spendabel gegenüber seinen treusten
capus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so profitierte abramowitsch zum beispiel
auch fürstlich von der zerschlagung des
yukos konzern zu seines konkurrenten
kolakowski der sich putin widersetzt
hatte und dafür zehn jahre im knast
landete wir haben über diese geschichte
schon in unserem vorletzten video
gesprochen und wer es noch nicht gesehen
hat kann es sich über den link hinter
dem ist symbolen und unten in der
beschreibung ansehen wegen all seiner
zwielichtigen geschäfte im mega format
und seiner verstrickung in kriminelle
machenschaften des kremls die regierung
trump abramowitsch als einer von
amerikas widersachern auf ihre
sanktionsliste und obwohl er in london
lebte und groß im gesamten königreich
engagiert war sowohl wirtschaftlich als
auch gesellschaft nicht verweigert in
großbritannien im mai 2018 die
verlängerung seines tier waren investor
visums er nahm daraufhin die israelische
staatsbürgerschaft an da als jude nach
den israelischen rückkehr gesetz ein
recht darauf hatte er blieb jedoch
trotzdem in london ankündigte nach
positiver verlauf die ukraine an seinen
chelsea zu verkaufen und den gewinn
daraus für ukrainische kriegsopfer
verschwenden um in seiner wahlheimat
doch noch irgendwie die wogen zu glätten
doch bevor er für den fußballclub einen
käufer finden konnte kam downing street
doch mit einem fetten sanktionspaket
gegen abramowitsch der grund seines
firmen waren zu stark an der aufrüstung
der russischen kriegsmaschinerie
beteiligt sein vermögen im vereinigten
königreich wurde eingefroren und sogar
seine einreise bis auf weiteres verboten
zuletzt wurde im märz 2002 als man sich
in dubai bei der suche nach stand es
gewesen willen gesichtet etwas weniger
bekannt ist der fall von alexander
tschäppät schnee ein russischer
millionär der über seine frau ins
vereinigte königreich ein heißt und dann
ein goldenes dieser erhielt wohl
interpol zu diesem zeitpunkt gegen ihn
wegen betrugs geldwäsche und
machtmissbrauchs ermittelt aber damit
wir uns nicht falsch verstehen nicht nur
russen sind auf dieser kontroversen
liste es gibt auch persönlichkeiten wie
den indischen milliardär nirav modi
gegen den auslieferungsverfahren wegen
geldwäsche läuft weil er die indische
bank ing und sage und schreibe 2
milliarden dollar betrogen haben soll
hinzu gesellt sich eine riesige haufen
kasachischer ukrainische und sogar
bangladesch millionäre politiker und
oligarchen die creme de la creme der
globalen krieg lukrativ die alle eines
gemeinsam haben sie haben ihr visum in
jener zeit des blinden vertrauens auf
der insel die erhöhte wachsamkeit und
ermittlungen gegen russische millionäre
haben dem gros des britischen fitter
wochen jedoch ein ende bereitet und seit
2008 zehn briten noch härter gegen die
fünfte kolonne moskaus vor erinnert sich
noch jemand was in diesem jahr in
großbritannien passiert ist wohlhabende
russen in großbritannien müssen nach
sorcery mit neuen wie sarrazin rechten
genau im jahr 2018 wurden der ehemalige
russische spion sergej skripal und seine
tochter von zwei russischen agenten mit
noch vergiftet
new york ist ein russisches gilt dass
während der sowjet ära entwickelt wurde
über buddhistische und darüber wie gift
im modernen russland als politische
waffe eingesetzt wird haben wir sogar
ein eigenes video gedreht hat sich
natürlich in der beschreibung verlinken
werde der punkt ist aber dass das
vereinigte königreich erkannt hat dass
die anwesenheit russische oligarchen die
präsident putin nahe stehen zu einem
nationalen sicherheitsproblem werden
könnte gut großbritannien ist nicht das
einzige land in dem politischen geld
lagern und die großen sind auch nicht
die einzigen die schwarzgeld im ausland
paris/london status als spielwiese für
krimmel navigation untergräbt
großbritanniens harte haltung gegenüber
russland großbritannien ist nicht das
einzige land in dem oligarchen geld
lagern und die russen sind auch nicht
die einzigen wie schwarzer dem ausland
partnern aber die ukraine krise hat die
britische regierung dazu veranlasst die
widersprüche zwischen ihre außenpolitik
und londons lockerer aufsicht
auszugleichen die britische regierung
zeigte bei der verhängung von sanktionen
gegen russland entschlossenheit aber bei
den oligarchen zögerte sie zunächst das
wurde sogar von der konservativen
zeitung le temps angeprangert
direkt am märz 2022 der zögerliche
fortschritt großbritanniens bei den
sanktionen wird langsam peinlich und
politisch bedenklich der grund für dich
inhalte taktik war ähnlich dem im
deutschen kanzleramt mann hatte die
süßen geschenke aus russland einfach zu
lieb gewonnen mit hilfe der kremlnahen
russischen oligarchen konnten sich alle
möglichen drahtzieher im königreich
bereichern anwaltskanzleien bankiers
sowie ist ein politiker architekten und
auch viele verschiedene unternehmer vom
gast und baugewerbe bis in die
luxusgüterbranche sie alle waren
abhängig und süchtig geworden nachdem
blutgeld der russen sowie die deutschen
nach ihrem blut gas und junkies stellen
ja meistens nicht so viele fragen wo
ihre drogen herkommen und wie vielen
menschen für die befriedigung ihrer
sucht bestohlen unterdrückt oder
ermordet wurden es interessiert sie
nicht auf wessen kosten sie ihren
nächsten schuss ihre kohle oder billiges
gas bekommen wir haben ja schon in einem
früheren video dazu aufgerufen das für
eure bundestagsabgeordnete zur rede
stellen sollte ob sie ein sofortiges und
vollständiges rohstoff embargo gegen
russland unterstützen oder nicht wir
haben sehr viel feedback dazu gekommen
und interessanterweise klingt die
argumentation der meisten embargo gegner
wie das pfeifen eines junkies der
einfach noch nicht wahrhaben will in was
für eine scheiße er sich und andere mit
seiner sucht hineingeritten hat hier
geht es jedoch langfristig darum ob wir
in europa frieden haben werden oder
kriegt ob wir die russische
kriegsmaschinerie weiterhin schmieren
wollen oder nicht laut dem obersten
diplomaten der eu bürger haben die
staaten der europäischen union seit
beginn des krieges ist anfang april sage
und schreibe 35 milliarden euro für
russische energie rohstoffe bezahlt
während die auslandshilfe die ukraine
nur eine milliarde euro betrug mit
anderen worten putins bericht einen
brutalen vernichtungskrieg los und
bekommt von der eu 35 milliarden euro
und sein opfer eine milliarde diese
zahlen lügen nicht und sie zeigen ganz
klar die krasse moralische und
sicherheitspolitischer schieflage auf in
welche uns politiker die schröder merkel
steinmeier und auch scholz geführt haben
eine skandalöse schieflage welche in
einer funktionierenden demokratie
eigentlich in untersuchungsausschüssen
aufgeklärt werden müsste ich meine all
diese leute wussten die ganze zeit voll
putins verbrechen und trotzdem haben sie
unsere volkswirtschaft von ihm abhängig
gemacht und niemand kann so naiv sein zu
glauben sie wären ein solches risiko ein
achso eingegangen ohne entsprechende
gegenleistung kein politiker ist und
schon gar nicht jene die mit allen
wassern gewaschen sind und es bis ganz
nach oben geschafft haben doch statt
eine untersuchung hören wir von ihm nur
schöne worte mit denen sie als akteure
der vergangenheit und gegenwart nicht
nur ihre verantwortung vertuschen wollen
sondern auch ihre jetzige hinhaltetaktik
die darauf schließen lässt dass ihre
worte nicht ehrlich gemeint sind weshalb
hier nochmal der aufruf das den
regierungsparteien vor allem der spd
diese scheinheilige ungefährliche
politik nicht durchlebt stellt eure
bundestagsabgeordneten zur rede das
video und den wir erklären wie dies am
besten geht habe ich euch hinter dem
symbol oben rechts verlinkt in
großbritannien hat der druck der
öffentlichkeit auf die regierung gewirkt
und die britischen london grad
profiteure müssten jetzt auf entzug eine
zäsur die den deutschen gas tankers noch
bevorsteht und die aber niemand herum
kommen wird
die deutsche wie auch die britische und
allgemein europäische spielwiese der
großen russischen mafia paten mit ihren
großzügigen geschenken wird so oder so
zu ende gehen die frage ist nur für wen
sie in würde zu ende gehen wird und für
wen in schande im vereinigten königreich
ist kein platz für schmutziges geld
diejenigen die putin unterstützen sind
gewarnt sie können ihre unrechtmässig
erworbenen gewinne nirgendwo verstecken
boris johnson premierminister des
vereinigten königreichs aber jetzt sei
erstmal ihr an der reihe was haltet ihr
von den hier beschriebenen dieses system
würde es in eurem land auch vorteile
bringen oder eher nachteile sollten die
empfänger sorgfältig gefiltert werden
oder sollte ein solches system jedem
investor offen stehen wie immer sind wir
auf eure beiträge und diskussionen zu
diesem wichtigen thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat und dabei vielleicht
etwas gelernt habt falls ja gibt es
einen live chat mit und freunden und
vergesst nicht dass aber mit glück noch
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich wollen wir es auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mittels hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den paper
link dazu findet in der beschreibung
unter diesem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]